there are some mean crashes in NASCAR F1
Indy and we're gonna watch some of the
meanest ones but know that everyone
survives in the clips that we're about
to watch and we're going to talk about
the medical situations in each of these
scenarios also huge thanks to
shipstation for sponsoring this video
[Music]
we got Formula One action honestly the
surviving F1 series is fire if you
haven't watched it yet
oh where would his body be it looks like
it would be split in pieces and the fact
that there's a fire I mean he's in a
fireproof suit but how long can that
help for oh there he is he's trying to
get out
oh my God you gotta spray him see the
problem with spraying down directly the
person is it's good and bad at the same
time good in that you're dousing the
flame but the reason you point the fire
extinguisher at the base of the flame is
to literally suffocate the flame and
when you're shooting it out of person's
face you're essentially suffocating the
person as well see the dangerous part
would be if he was knocked unconscious
because then he wouldn't be able to
climb out of the car
look you could see that the medical
delegate is trying so hard to get near
him but the Flames must be so hot
it burned his hand burns to the hand are
so bad because of the contractors that
can form that the skin essentially
starts becoming flexed and you're going
to need multiple surgeries usually and
occupational therapy shout out to my
occupational therapists out there to
help work that hand open and keep its
shrink or recover its strength wow he's
walking away from this and if you're
walking my guy's running away from me
not only has he survived going through a
barrier
a 160 miles an hour
160 miles an hour and how is he not
concussed going from 160 miles an hour
to zero so quickly the danger in crashes
is going from a high speed to a zero
speed because all of that inertia
carries your organs forward even the
brain the brain sits in a soup so it
starts hitting the front of your scalp
when you come to an abrupt stop and I
know they have neck stabilizing devices
in the car but whoa It's insisted no no
no we'll we'll get the ambulance here
but he wanted to demonstrate that he was
okay he got a message to everyone his
wife and family in particular okay
beautiful message medically I hate it
adrenaline in moments like this is
rushing so fast that you might not have
any idea what's going on in your body
you might be bleeding internally you
might be bleeding internally into your
skull having a stroke so many things
could be going wrong right now and just
to symbolize that you're great and
strong you do the extra walk unnecessary
actually it's the same reason in boxing
once there's a knockout they don't have
have people just usually stand up right
away after the match ends they first
bring them to a stool they have them
calm down in the stool and they evaluate
what's going on there and have the
doctor speak with them then they have
them stand up and they redo it again and
there's reasons for this progression
because we want to make sure that the
body and mind are both safe looks like
he only suffered minor burns to the back
of his hands a sprained left ankle and
was discharged from the hospital soon
after that's crazy that that's all that
happened I mean I sprayed my right ankle
walking through the refrigerator the
other day on Bear's toy and this guy's
surviving 160 mile an hour wreck side
making a move okay Indy for those of you
who don't know I was with Mario Andretti
in an Indy car did a lap how about you
oh they're gonna touch Wheels they're
gonna touch Wheels oh they touch wheels
on a turn that's awful oh my God that's
Robin Williams
they got everybody
oh my God the spins
the strain and force a spin like that
puts on your neck I can't even begin to
understand because when I took those
turns with Andretti I felt it in my neck
like my whole head being pushed to one
side when you're spinning like that
constantly changing direction the amount
of G's is incredible nothing like even
my F-16 experience
violent crash Pocono Raceway which is
where I did mine by the way confirmed
Thursday night that he is paralyzed from
the chest down no way so if chest down
likely that means that there was some
kind of spinal cord injury and obviously
from a spin like that as I was saying
you're putting so much torque on the
spinal cord that it's no surprise that
there was severe damage Ryan Newman off
turn four for the final time Blaney to
the outside fish selling they're selling
fish
why why oh my God in a shower of Sparks
across the line fourth Newman got turned
Jesus went up in the air as he came down
was hit by another car and launched
Skyward you know in traditional car
accidents uh like on the highway they
have this device called the jaws of life
to actually cut through the doors and
other mechanical obstacles that might be
in the way to free passengers I wonder
how they do it here tries to go to the
outside then the inside they look
bumpers
inside there
a lot of pressure on the neck being
upset like this is okay again there's no
rapid stop where you have that inertia
of the organs potentially experiencing a
high G-Force so this sliding effect is
actually life-saving he would later hold
an interview with today on March 11th
where he discussed the crash revealing
he was knocked out and sustained a
bruised brain Bru's brain essentially he
had a concussion probably a counter cool
injury from getting hit on one side and
remember when the brain hits one side it
then automatically bounces to the other
side because it sits in that soup it's
called a counter coup injury but glad to
know that he's alive let's take a minute
and talk about ship station the leading
web-based order management and shipping
software it's designed to make retailers
lives Easier by making processing
fulfilling and shipping e-commerce
orders more efficient I know how
difficult it is running an online
business I mean I'm launching new merch
so I understand the value of having the
right tools before you get started
shipping can become total chaos during
the holidays too as orders increase and
everyone is panicking to get their gifts
in on time that doesn't have to be your
life though thanks to shipstation you
could focus on growing your business
from day one as they eliminate all the
headaches that come with printing labels
or handling orders across multiple
platforms like Amazon
Etsy eBay even your own website one of
the best parts of shipstation is that
you can get the same discounted shipping
rates as Fortune 500 companies
regardless of how much you're selling
over a hundred thirty thousand companies
have grown their e-commerce business
with ship station and 98 of those
companies that use them for one year
become customers for life this holiday
season give yourself the gift of
stress-free holiday shipping go to
shipstation.com Dr Mike remember doctor
is spelled out and sign up for a free
60-day trial that's right
shiftstation.com Dr Mike start today and
get set up before the biggest shipping
season of the year
level checkered as
it is what earlier Evan Winston Rusty
Smith then get there oh he's flying he's
flying rolling rolling
okay if I'm trying to gauge the risk of
an accident this is probably one of the
safest ones we've seen so far not to
downplay the injuries that happen here
but because again the car kept rolling
that looks terrifying but usually
creates the safest stop for the car
because again it's that sudden stop and
the speed of that stop the deceleration
that causes the most damage and is the
most lethal yeah he's moving I see him
moving around in the car it
again usually what results from this is
neck injuries concussions from the
rolling around maybe if your hand gets
caught in something that's why I think
Formula One drivers and I don't know
about other racing sports are taught to
take their hands immediately off the
wheel on an accident thankfully Wallace
simply lucky to be alive given the
severity of the incident didn't suffer
any severe injuries he did however
suffer some minor ones and was forced to
wear a cast on his hand for the next few
races his accident inspired the
introduction of roof flaps to NASCAR
Vehicles which work to reduce flipping
when cars go Airborne I mean a cast with
a crash of that severity is a pretty
good thing to get away with but you can
see Mike moving inside the car all the
Airborne ones are so bad oh my God oh my
God see some of the most dangerous Parts
here are when the car that is Airborne
and its Wheels make contact with the
other driver from their head which is
unprotected and I know in Formula One
they started creating some sort of
protection for them I don't know if this
was instituted at the time of this race
here in turn three and four corner a few
years ago wow and the car is up into the
fence which is almost reminiscent of
Kenny Brax accident at Texas quite a few
years ago guys very very lucky yeah so
he went body into the fence which again
takes a major toll on your spinal cord
because imagine you're sitting and your
spinal cord experiences all those
compressive forces puts pressure on your
discs I wouldn't be surprised if there's
a disc herniation involved here bulging
disc maybe even a disc rupture from the
severity of that injury Conway had
surgery for multiple fractures in his
lower left leg and had been diagnosed
with a compression fracture in his back
that's interesting because I was talking
about this compression but the vertebrae
which are the actual bony bodies in
between the discs can fracture as well
must have been a lot of damage to his
spine but uh definitely can recover with
surgery from that whoa oh look out we
got trouble oh my God for the people in
the stands
and for the car oh my God oh my God
multiple hits
the whole race is over so Jeffrey is
alert at least and conscious and able to
move I don't know about you guys but I'm
breathing a little bit better right now
I mean I'm not because you're still not
out of danger until you're in the
hospital even in the hospital when we
have a patient in one area and we need
to transfer them whether it's from a
regular inpatient floor unit to the ICU
or from the ER to the patient room that
Transportation can only happen when the
patient's stable and things go wrong
during that transportation that you need
to be present and ready to activate a
code blue a rapid response and treat the
patient right then and there he suffered
a concussion facial laceration multiple
bruises right wrist fracture and a small
fracture to a vertebrae and is an
intensive care unit serious but stable
condition wow I would say that it's
probably a very severe concussion uh
when you're being tossed around at that
rate of speed I mean that that's
incredible just as I walk out in
infirmary they said Lee Petey just went
over turned three and four walls
oh this looks like something from the
scene of a card game called Carmageddon
I don't know if you guys remember that
game or Twisted Metal
yeah I think I also couldn't afford the
real game but I got my hands on a demo
disc and I just played a demo over and
over I went in to talk to him he was
about half conscious and I'll just tore
all the pieces cut up everywhere ribs
broke and punctured lung just his leg oh
just all busted off just hanging there
that's the biggest danger that I always
tell you guys about whenever there's a
rib fracture about puncturing your lung
and developing a pneumothorax also less
talked about but equally dangerous is if
that rib fractures in an area where it
Nicks your aorta you have massive
internal bleeding that's a deadly deadly
injury Lee Petty's car was destroyed and
then they took his broken apparently
lifeless body to the hospital it was
some time before he could have broken
bones fixed they waited to see if he
would stabilize as he lay in a coma he
spent four months in the hospital Petty
did return to racing but he was never
quite as competitive again wow oh
throwback okay let's see what happens oh
oh wow okay those are the ones I'm
talking about where you're going high
rate of speed and then you come to an
end and stop that's where you lose your
life there's Michael Waltrip now
standing up climbing out from around
that shredded mangled massive sheet
metal well he's just walking out Pontiac
Grand Prix just a few moments ago yeah
Ben I think I'm all right uh got some
contusions and a little bit of confusion
but uh that's probably not too unusual
That's Not Unusual that is unusual when
we decide whether or not to scan
someone's head for an intracranial bleed
it's based off of certain signs and
symptoms but also the mechanism of
injury and going 100 miles an hour or
whatever that was to zero is most
definitely a high speed accident
warranting a full body CAT scan I think
I'm all right and we'll go home get a
good night's rest tonight no you don't
go home you go straight to the hospital
I hope you went to the hospital you know
my seat stayed secured in the frame rail
in in the only frame rail really that
stayed as a part of the back of the car
this part
I think the only thing that really saved
him here was that he hit the outside of
his car not his own side it was the
driver's side that had that impact it
would have been a very different outcome
Alonzo let's go this is McLaren days not
Ferrari days oh there goes his front
tire oh it's so hard to make out what
just happened is he okay the whole axle
he walked away like that that's him
wait is that Esteban Gutierrez
that's my friend look at all these
pictures of me and him you see this guy
then you see the ground you see the sky
and you know exactly where you are and
you keep moving moving you want to stop
then they gotta stop I saw a little
space to go out and I said I go out
quickly and my mom will watch TV so I
want to be out quite say that I'm okay I
feel fine physically but everything
hurts a little because you move around
so much at those speeds the knees what
bothers me most is it hit the steering
column but I feel very lucky very lucky
everything is going to hurt for a while
and honestly you should be under
observation because if you're even
having a small bleed internally you want
to make sure that you're able to act
quickly so I have a funny story with
Esteban Gutierrez we went to our family
dinner I took him on my Audi TTS and I
was gonna drop him off at his place and
then go home and I'm with the Formula
One driver I'm gonna drive and try and
look cool and because of that I turned
into the Holland Tunnel in the city and
I didn't mean to do that so I was like
oh my God I turned into the wrong thing
so I was like let me just back up real
quick it's not I'm not that far in and
as soon as I started backing up you see
a cop walk out onto the street and go
excuse me sir come on come on and had me
pull up check my windows for tints
started writing me tickets I was like
officer I'm so sorry I made this mistake
I'm a physician this is a Formula One
driver he's like I couldn't care less
here's your tin ticket but yeah that
that's that goes to say that even if you
have a Formula One driver in your
passenger seat don't try and show off
because things will go wrong
oh no oh no this is gonna be the worst
one isn't it
foreign
the only thing that I'll say is this is
pretty low speed so I guess that's a
little bit safer but these vehicles
weren't as safe so that's not
necessarily true you know what's really
scary when you watch some uh of those
videos when there is a blizzard and
there's low visibility and then there's
an accident and another accident and all
of a sudden there's cars just sliding
into other cars and then people come out
to see what's going on and they're
getting trapped never exit your vehicle
if you're in one of those situations
call for help stay in your vehicle
because you don't know what's coming
behind you that's the scary part and if
you do exit run away like don't stay on
the highway I mentioned earlier that I
flew in F-16 check out that video right
here I'm doing barrel rolls upside down
twisties 9 G's over 90s seriously click
here to watch that and don't forget to
visit tripstation.com Dr Mike to begin
your 60-day free trial as always stay
happy and help
[Music]